29 and eight coming in on this one and
we mentioned a tar heel in the house and
uh
yes
oh yes
i saw you i saw you i had them all today
i put the sneakers on today baby i was
like i am not losing and i'm touching
the wall shack because i know how to
come at the end
you can get this hair cut or you can
have it
this is what you want in life
and this is whatever i don't know this
is chuck with that technology
on the right that's you want to learn
that
you went on the left more like you're
the one on the right
that's me and that's i think that's my
senior prom picture
on the left with the texturizer
[Laughter]
you got the little s curl going
back in the day
i don't know
anyway but no you talking about cam
johnson when i when he was in college
basketball i i've tried to build the
perfect player and i said the perfect
player i want to have his right hand
because he shoots the ball so incredibly
every time this guy shoots the
basketball i think it's going in but
you're playing with devin booker and
another guy who can get this shot he
gives you space but the other thing that
he's doing so much better he's putting
the ball on the floor and he's getting
to the rim so freeze it here that shot
here was not a consistent shot for him
in college and or as his first couple of
years in the nba but that in-between
shot now has made him a deadly player
but then when you pick and roll and you
let him go and give him space you cannot
give him space you have to stay with the
roller and then the last part so he's
got the three he's got the in between
but the other thing is he doesn't stay
he doesn't settle anymore he gets into
the areas drives the lane and finishes
so his ability to score multiple ways is
probably the best thing and i was ready
for you today chuck i was ready i didn't
want to break your comfort at this
earlier yeah
i'm not losing the race in 2022
[Music]
i'm not losing in 2022
okay okay what are we betting on that
i don't care who's in here anything one
no no no no just you got normal bets
okay i'll normal bet every time i lose
but every time i win you gotta give me
the normal bet too so that would be one
i went up
21 straight games by the way for cameron
johnson with at least two threes